et ça lui c'est loïc le monteur juste
pour vous dire le nouveau livre de
fabien est sorti c'est un livre sur le
temps qu'il vous présente dans la vidéo
précédente
bon bah voilà c'est tout pour moi allez
bonne vidéo
la lune en sagittaire c'est un type qui
peut avoir des réflexes assez franc
assez après une à mercure cancer faut se
méfier ce qu'on lui raconte pas ce qu'il
doit à une mémoire d'éléphant berthod
[Musique]
salut youtube il ya quelques semaines
j'ai posté sur ma chaîne une vidéo où je
recevais un astrologue et je vous avais
dit on pose un peu notre eau et ont fait
ce truc là d'une manière divertissante
et et envoie un petit peu ce qui se
passe et aujourd'hui nous allons
analyser cette vidéo la c1 l'astrologue
mon propre comportement également ça va
être juste passionnant d'ailleurs s'il
ya quelque chose qui vous a choqué dans
la vidéo de l'astrologue regarder ce que
je vais dire maintenant si rien ne vous
a choqué aller directement à ceux
timecode la voilà et sinon restez we you
want your vous êtes resté donc vous avez
été choqué par l'une des deux choses qui
est le plus revenir dans les
commentaires on va prendre la première
chose la première chose c'est quoi un
astrologue sur la chaîne de fabien mais
eux même si c'est pour faire un
décryptage même si mais qu'est ce qui
fait au lit car il fait ce qu'il veut
voilà ça c'était la première réponse est
tout et est en plus assez clairement mis
dans la description et en commentaire
épinglé la deuxième chose qui a pu vous
choquer c'est alors ouais ok pourquoi il
n'ya que des hommes qui ont été pris
dans les enveloppes
alors je vais vous dire pourquoi y'a que
des hommes qui ont été pris dans les
enveloppes et pourquoi on s'est pris la
tête à mettre le genre sur chacune des
enveloppes c'est une excellente question
alors qu'il n'y avait que des hommes
parce qu'au départ il est plus dans blow
up dont il y avait un mélange d'hommes
et femmes et après on a sélectionné
réserve c'est tombé que sur des hommes
vous êtes sur la chaîne qui a reçu le
plus de femmes du youtube game avec un
équilibre parfait entre le nombre de
femmes et le nombre d'hommes que j'ai
reçu pareil quand c'est des abonnés il
ya toujours l'équilibré entre les hommes
et les femmes mais par contre les mêmes
personnes qui m'ont bien casser la tête
dans les commentaires avec ça vous étiez
où quand clara morgane s'est fait
vraiment insulté dans mes commentaires
laetitia du corps la maison l'esprit
lola dubigny fanny fiq virginie calhoun
céline âge vous êtes tous à chaque fois
parce que moi je me bats vraiment dans
les commentaires quand les femmes se
font insulter pour rien je vais faire du
nettoyage je vais répondre les éduquer
alors au lieu de chercher à m'éduquer
sur le fait que les enveloppes prises au
hasard était que celle des hommes
j'aimerai vous voir venir éduquer les
personnes qui sont insultants auprès des
femmes que je reçois merci beaucoup
voici la démarche du jour la démarche de
l'autre jour c'était on vit ce
divertissement là on voit ce qui se
passe et on le fait avec le plus de
bienveillance possible aujourd'hui la
méthodologie c'est de regarder tout ça
avec un esprit critique mais toujours
bienveillant
j'ai toutes les latitudes
clay l'attitude déclamait de notre
système solaire c'est ce qu'on appelle
le support est ce intéressant parce
qu'il en a qui est très précis en fait
il va pas dire des choses au hasard
il va sûrement adapter ce qui va dire si
on va devoir par la suite mais en tout
cas de base il va utiliser un support ce
que j'aurais pu faire au départ c'est le
faire en double aveugle c'est ce que je
dis à la fin de la vidéo pourquoi aussi
j'ai pas voulu le faire en double
aveugle dès le départ pour pouvoir faire
cette vidéo comme moi je connais ce
qu'il ya dans les enveloppes
alors jean yves six en tout cas il doit
se référer à moi et on va voir ça plus
tard
il peut se servir de moi comme support à
ce moment puis c'est un mec qui tient
pas en place l'une sagittaire ça donne
des gens qui voyagent qu'ils bougent pas
besoin de mobilité permanente après une
amère que le cancer faut se méfier ce
qu'on lui raconte alors je m'arrête là
parce qu'il ya trois choses
intéressantes à dire la première chose
c'est que moi je bénéficie d'un ancrage
mental j'ai vu déjà jean yves dans un
restaurant faire le thème de loïc de
fanny de ces lignes de moi et que
c'était relativement probants et c'était
très intéressant de le voir faire donc
j'ai un ancrage positif envers lui la
deuxième chose c'est que on n'est pas
sur un biais des faits d' ambiguïté là
tout ce qui vient de dire sur trump au
départ il n'y a pas ce fameux de ce
fameux truc de tout et son contraire non
et la troisième chose c'est que je
commence à avoir des caractéristiques
qu'on utilise encore le reading j'ai
pris près de moi ma bible ça a été mon
premier livre dans le col reading ex
nihilo d'angel stagnaro je vous mettrais
un lien dans la description je ne sais
pas si on peut encore le trouver mais si
on peut le trouver je vous mettrais un
lien on a on a pas mal de choses là
dessus
la 7e règles du kolding par exemple
c'est utiliser un accessoire donc le
support dont je vous parlais la 18e rex
et théâtralisée l'instant surjoue un peu
la scène soignée théâtrale bouger les
mains et c'est la 28e rex et par levi
parler sans cesse ne dit rien votre
représentation doit être constamment
rempli de vos paroles ou celle de votre
spectateurs seuls les moments de
concentration silencieuse judicieusement
placés çà et là au cours de votre
performance qu'on vous cherchez à
distinguer les esprits ou autres sont
acceptables dans la pièce tous les yeux
sont fixés sur vous et tout le monde est
concentré sur ce que vous dites quand
vous parlez rapidement les spectateurs
ont du mal à saisir ce que vous dites
un disque aux rapides et difficiles à se
rappeler et plonge le spectateur dans
une confusion en général ils se
rappelleront seulement des quelques
points principaux de la lecture qu'ils
savent être vrai ça peut donner un type
qui va avoir un compté dominant parce
qu'on sait depuis 4000 ans qu'un corse
qu'un gamin
des marchés l'action l'agressivité à
l'attention là on a un billet de
tradition quand j'arrive dit parce qu'on
sait depuis 4000 ans donc c'est une
espèce de forme d'autorité qui
inconsciemment te fait admettre de abba
apparemment on sait ça depuis 4000 ans
donc c'est fait que c'est vrai que ça
n'apporte rien au débat en fait après on
rentre dans un biais qui s'appelle
l'illusion des séries puisque quand même
je considère qu'ils abondent à tuer
qu'il a bon là dessus il doit aussi
avoir bon là dessus c'est un espèce de
biais de confirmation d'hypothèses on
peut l'appeler également comme ça la
chose qu'on n'a pas pour l'instant et
c'est ça qui est intéressante par
rapport à ce que j'ai dit dans les
commentaires tout le monde s'est targué
devoir de l'effet barnum partout il ya
énormément de biais cognitifs comme on
vient de le voir il ya une grande
possibilité de cold reding à coup quasi
certain de l'adaptation vis-à-vis de ma
propre lecture non verbale sur mes
réactions
mais l'effet barnum bahia pas vraiment
là je comprends que ce mot soit
intéressant et qu'on veuille l'employé
souvent mais revoyons la définition de
l'effet barnum attention générique effet
barnum l'effet barnum effet fohrer effet
de validation subjectif ou encore effet
de bali dation personnel d in habillé
connectif induisant toute personne
acceptée une vague d'ex cription de la
personnalité comme s'appliquant
spécifiquement à elle-même
donc c'est foreurs qui a fait ça en 1948
et à petit on l'a appelé l'effet barnum
par rapport à filer à ce barnum ses
grands châteaux etc et les faits barnum
c'est vraiment de décrire des choses
vague de jean rolin sur le sur le test
de foreur c'était vous avez besoin
d'être aimé et admiré et pourtant vous
êtes critique envers vous même vous êtes
certes des points faibles dans votre
personnalité mais vous savez
généralement les compenser
là on disait tout et son contraire il
fait par nomme c'est le fait de se
retrouver à l'intérieur de ça et de
remettre en avant les éléments qui nous
correspondait de ce gars est une
description parfaite de moi là en
l'occurrence c'est pas le cas puisqu'il
ne joue pas sur son contraire donc les
800 milliards de commentaires sur effet
barnum battant par contre vous auriez pu
nommer énormément d'autres biais
cognitifs mais pas les faits barnum
d'ailleurs c'est un billet le fait de
vouloir absolument utiliser un mot qu'on
connaît en pensant que c'est ça qu'on
voit à chaque fois parce qu'on l'a
appris ces dernières années en fait il
là il aurait vraiment fallu élargir tant
qu'à faire on va parler vite fait encore
de cold reading parce que j'avais trouvé
un truc qui était très intéressant sur
le site des sceptiques du canada ou
dessus on a le petit
bob rae inman je crois qui a travaillé
en tant que psychique pour financer ses
études
donc il faisait croire qu'il avait des
pouvoirs psy est lui qui avait un passif
de magicien mentaliste l'utiliser du
cold redding et nous écrit quelque chose
sur le col de reading les cinq règles
que lui utilisé et elles sont très
intéressantes si on met en parallèle la
lecture avec un astrologue comme la
selle avec jean-yves un tu dois agir en
confiance n'a pas besoin d'être arrogant
en fait il te sera probablement
bénéfique de feindre l'humilité 2 tu
dois toujours faire tes recherches il te
faut être à jour dans les statistiques
par exemple savoir que les écrasements
d'avions ont lieu surtout en avril que
la peur des avions quelque chose de
rouge sur l'or que etc sache que les
gens en général correspondent
parfaitement aux statistiques aussi tu
doit récolter dans la conversation
informelle qui précédera la performance
toutes les informations qui pourraient
être utiles plus tard comme parler un
caméra même durant l'après-midi et puis
durant la performance du soir être
contactés par son défunt père don et a
parlé précédemment la l'utilisation
d'informations
là j'arrive ne pouvait pas le faire
qu'il ne savait pas qu'il y avait dans
les enveloppes mais on ne sait pas comme
il savait que c'était des personnalités
il a pu aussi s'imprégner des dates de
naissance de grandes personnalités
là ce que je dis n'a aucune valeur même
pas hypothétique sais c'est possible de
le faire quand ils l'avaient fait ils
nous auraient fait quand même des trucs
encore plus précis pour nos bleus
3 tu dois convaincre son auditeur qu'il
ou elle sera la raison de son succès ou
de ton échec
en fait c'est vrai puisque son client
qui va de fournir malgré lui des
informations vitales qui rendront les
prédictions si troublante de vérité
c'est dans la nature humaine de chercher
du sens donc cela ne sera pas difficile
pour toi à ce niveau et là on le voit
par exemple quand même raconte tout le
truc du lion un peu cossart feignant mme
errecart même temps le roi etc
on me voit si tu veux remettre la
séquence le hic explosé de rire et
baissé la tête
parce que oui je trouve que ça marche
que l'image se retrempe palais assez
drôle bon en clair je viens de lui
servir sur un plateau d'argent le fait
qu'il était dans la bonne voie iv soit
observateurs est ce que la personne
porte un bijou coûte des vêtements
simples là on est sur la base du corps
ding cinq utilise la flatterie effet
comme si tu en savez plus que tu n'en
c'est là la flatterie sur moi n'est pas
possible évidemment fait comme si tu en
savez plus que tu n'en sais où vous oui
ça peut donner cette impression parce
que comme il utilise beaucoup de noms de
la planète qui me dit bah ça ça fait
quatre mille ans qu'on le sait que moi
je le sais pas je me sens un petit peu
un culte et je me dis lui il sait
reprenons cette vidéo allons donc d'un
jeune homme
qui est née le 27 janvier 1996 un homme
squeeze ces intéressantes de ce que je
connais jean yves c'est une certitude
qui l'a jamais fait le thème de squeeze
il connaît pas vraiment youtube games il
a des dates de personnalités en tête ce
sera pas celle ci j'aime bien voir sa
réaction à ce moment là et ça trahit pas
une angoisse quelconque on voit vraiment
du bout des lèvres il y la date et se
précipite sur son support pour chercher
la date mais y'a pas un
mon dieu celle ci je l'est pas du tout
je vois pas qui ça peut être donc c'est
intéressant parce que je me dis par
contre vraiment je suis certain à ce
moment-là qu'il n'a pas fait de
recherche parce que ça ne déstabilise
pas il va sur son support il utilise ces
méthodes ça je trouvais ça intéressant
de le préciser
vers qui il est partagé entre le bénin
dans son canapé en cuir avec ses bonnes
choses à boulotter et en même temps le
sac à dos qui prennent dans l'entrée où
il a qu'une envie c'est se barrer et le
le dîner et nuit doivent permanent il à
mercure capricorne donc là on a un petit
peu plus d'ambiguïtés parce qu'ils nous
parlent d'un dilemme donc deux
possibilités en même temps et surtout il
ya quelque chose de compliqué comme il
décrypte de squeeze et que on connaît
pas squeeze personnellement dans son
quotidien je je je peux pas amené de
validation poche j'ai juste l'image que
je me fais de squeeze et ce qui pourrait
marcher ou pas je vais être bourré de
piller qui vont confirmer ça parce que
je me dis oui potentiellement je trouve
que ça marche mais en vrai j'en sais
rien il ya que squeeze qui pourrait nous
dire si vraiment ça s'applique à lui ou
pop caractère dominant dominant de
l'hymne au soleil on sait je suis le roi
le centre le chef etc
le lion considère qu'il est le centre du
monde là où l'adulte c'est là où je le
trouve fort moi je ne crois pas
intention que ce soit bien clair au
pouvoir de l'astrologie ce genre de
choses et je me dis non on n'est pas sur
l'effet barnum quand on n'est pas sur un
effet d'ambiguïté il va direct quoi il
nous dit voilà c'est un dominant dominé
dominant énorme dôme dans bon si la
personne n'est pas dominante
ça marche pas point il n'ya pas il n'y a
pas de revers possible donc c'est un
type qui est branché combat en
permanence il est dans les rapports de
force en permanence
après là j'ai commencé à valider on voit
ma tête là qui est encore plus franches
par rapport à tout à l'heure quand vous
avez remis l'image c'était très léger
donc là la franchise
en tout cas c'est un signal fort que je
lui envoie en non verbal de ouais c'est
sûr c'est exactement ça donc là son
assistance dessus peut être lié à ça
l'intuition un peu anxiogène de qui va
me bouffe et de l'espace qui va être
manipulé quitte à la description qui en
découlent ont l'impression que ces deux
nouvelles informations en réalité
quelqu'un de dominant à de fortes
chances statistiques d'avoir le profil
psychologique suivant in a year en fait
quelqu'un qui est encore dans le détail
là on a eu encore des informations qui
colle au profil psychologique d'un
dominante repin ailleurs très dans le
détail
sans oublier que j'ai fait une
validation très fort de la tête sur le
oui qui a pu le conforter à lever à
aller dessus je pense quand même qu'on a
toutes les caractéristiques d'un col de
raideurs classique je vais vous lire
deux trois trucs encore de kolding
qu'ils vont vous parler dans le but de
divertir un pas dans le fait de
pratiquer le kolding la pensée sélective
est un processus psychologique
inconscient par lequel le spectateur
choisit de se rappeler de se focaliser
uniquement sur les signes les
informations positif et d'oublier ce qui
ne l'est pas même si c'est manifestement
exact l'horoscope en est un exemple
classique la plupart des informations
fournies dans la description des
caractéristiques afférentes à chaque
signe sont positives et peuvent convenir
un grand nombre de personnes qu'ils
soient ou non nés sous ce signe de plus
depuis millions d'années que les signes
traditionnelle du zodiaque ont été
établies les constellations ne
correspondent plus au mois auquel a été
attribué à l'origine mais c'était
important aussi que je joue le jeu
réellement de la personne en face parce
que sinon c'était juste se payer un
astrologue et c'est pas le but quoi
tient ce titre là une des règles aussi
du goldwing c'est de clarifier lorsqu'on
a bon et c'est ce qu'on voit
dès que dès que moi j'envoie un message
non verbale ou d'ailleurs verbale ça
m'est arrivé dans la vidéo de we ça me
parle et reformulé airs clarifier encore
plus précisément mais là où je trouve
que quand même genre yves est très bon
c'est qu'il n'a pas utilisé ce qu'on
appelle les
et lieux communs les lieux communs qui
justement s'applique à tout le monde
dieu commun on va faire un petit lieu
commun sur surtout à loïc donc tu es un
homme tué un jeune homme plutôt beau mec
de poids du jour à intellectuelle moi
j'ai vu testory donc en prenant ça je
sais à peu près statistiquement ce qui
te concerne loïc quand le besoin s'en
fait sentir vous êtes une personne
plutôt créative sensible et sage quand
c'est nécessaire de se concentrer
par exemple sur un projet vous savez
aussi vous montrer charmant quand vous
avez besoin de convaincre les autres et
du coup vous pouvez vous sortir de
presque n'importe quelle situation et
vous sentez rarement débordé ça peut
arriver mais en fait vous fait confiance
que toute votre vie vous avez toujours
réussi au final à chaque fois vous en
sortir même des fois où vous vous êtes
dit c'est fou en fait je passe toujours
à travers des mailles c'est vrai vous
voyez de quoi je parle
cette situation du passé qui était
pourtant si oppressante et quasiment du
jour au lendemain
vous avez repris le dessus vous êtes
sorti loïc c'est complètement fou
d'ailleurs ne laissez personne vous
précipitez vous pousser dans une
décision à considérer ok ça vous est
déjà arrivé dans le passé et après vous
avez regretté proposer toujours le choix
ne vous laissez pas avoir par la
sympathique vous avez envers une
personne
voilà je viens te balancer plein de
phrases qui s'appelle des lieux communs
que je que je prenais comme ça au pif en
fait autant et là je disais rien de
particulier mais quand même tu te sens
concerné par ça imagine qu au milieu de
ça je met des choses un peu plus précis
sur les statistiques que je fasse du col
de reading c'est à dire en fonction de
comment tu es habillée et cetera de ce
que je vois de toit de ce que je peux
percevoir de toi comme dans la vidéo
call trading qu'on avait fait ici là je
vais la mettre au dessus si j'y pense
si je n'y pense pas quand les lieux dans
les commentaires ben on obtient une
séance de voyance très forte et très
crédible
bon moi je ne change pas d'avis je n'ai
pas de croyance vis-à-vis de
l'astrologie
mais je trouve intéressant de voir des
astrologues travail et j'en ai vu plein
de comabi je suis allé souvent dans les
salons de voyance parce que ça
m'intéresse
jean yves est sûrement le meilleur que
j'ai vu dans son domaine parce que je ne
joue pas de l'ambiguïté hilda direct et
ça c'est très fort on sent les trente
ans d'expérience je pense aussi qu'ils
connaissent on me qui parker c'est à
dire que tout ce qui dit par rapport aux
planètes tout ça est vrai vrai dans le
sens la méthode d'origine de
l'astrologie dit ça il s'appuie sur
cette méthode là à 100% et il est aussi
très bon en terme de show man
ty parle vite il laisse pas le temps je
pense qu'il est aussi fin psychologue et
qui réagit à tout ce que moi j'en vois
de l'autre côté et je pense qu'il est
très bon call raider et là vous allez me
dire mais oui mais il connaissait pas
les personnes non on connaissait le sexe
est l'année de naissance de la personne
donc il a quand même des informations
importantes on sait que c'est un homme
on sait qu'il a tel âge et qu'il est né
à telle époque et a priori que c'est une
personnalité puisque j'avais dit que je
prendrais des personnalités donc ça
comme fait quand même pas mal
d'informations pour col red et de là à
savoir si lui fait tout ça et se sert
aussi des biais cognitifs et de la
lecture non verbale et du col reading
sciemment ou inconsciemment
personnellement ça mon hypothèse je
pense qu'il le fait inconsciemment
j'en veux pour preuve le moment où on
prend le thème de squeeze et vraiment il
se jette sur son trône et qui va lire
tout de suite pour composer tout ça bon
tout en ayant l'âge de la personne et
fait que ce soit un garçon
ils se prétendent pas voyant et près de
votre temps pas du tout avoir des super
pouvoirs je pense que lui croit en la
méthodologie de l'astrologie là où moi
en l'occurrence je n'y crois pas et que
à force avec le temps il a su sûrement
lire inconsciemment aussi la réaction
des personnes en phase escrocs pour moi
non vraie science pour moi par contre
non plus c'est tout ce que j'avais à
dire là dessus je trouvais intéressant
de décrypter ça j'ai une autre vidéo qui
viendra dans le temps sur le domaine de
la voyance qui va aller beaucoup plus
loin que çà ou là on sera pas sûr de la
bienveillance mais on va être quand même
sur quelques choses à l'envers et plus
dans le piège complet mais ça va être
intéressant parce que là encore une fois
on a affaire à quelqu'un de gentil qui
ne prétend pas avoir des pouvoirs est
juste une croyance en astrologie
pour moi ça reste nos pseudo science
comment ça se passe envers les voyants
qui disent avoir des flashs ça c'est
encore autre chose dont les dates de
spectacles c'est reparti en tournée
sa part dans toute la france la belgique
la suisse partout je veux pas répéter
les dates mais à les voir parce qu'après
vous dites quand est-ce que tu passes
mais c'est passé donc n'hésitez pas
check et ça nous envoie soir à très
bientôt ciao bye au revoir merci hasta
la vista et commencer à tourner je
foutais des soucoupes moi ça